FOR THE LEAK THEORY THAT IS
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT.
WE BEGIN WITH DR. GIROIR.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY.
YOU KNOW, I SPOKE WITH
DR. FRANCIS COLLINS LAST WEEK OF
THE NIH, THE HEAD OF THE NIH.
HE SORT OF SCOFFED AT THE NOTION
THAT THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
NEFARIOUS PURPOSE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS VIRUS.
BUT YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK INTO
THIS REPORT THAT CAME OUT IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" THIS
WEEKEND BY DR. MULLER, THEY TALK
APART THE COMPOSITION OF THIS
VIRUS AND THEY ARGUE THERE'S A
LOT OF TIMES IN THE GENOME THAT
IT MAY WELL HAVE COME FROM THE
LAB.
>> SO I THINK WHAT WE KNOW,
MARTHA IS THAT 81,000 SAMPLES IN
NATURE, THERE WAS NO VIRUS OF
DECADES OF THE EVOLUTION OF
COVID-19.
WE KNOW THE WUHAN LAB DID
RESEARCH ON BAT CORONAVIRUSES,
HOW THEY COULD ATTACK HUMAN
RECEPTORS LIKE THE A-2 RECEPTORS
IN LUNGS AND THERE WAS MILITARY
INVOLVEMENT.
SO THE EVIDENCE IS
CIRCUMSTANTIAL BUT IT'S BECOMING
TRULY COMPELLING THIS WAS AT
LEAST A LAB LEAK.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A VIRUS THAT
THEY COLLECTED BUT MORE LIKELY A
VIRUS THAT THEY MADE IN SOME
WAY.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT.
I'M HEARING THAT A LOT WITH
PEOPLE STUDYING THE SITUATION.
THEY SAY MOST LIKELY IT WAS AN
INADVERTENT LEAK?
WHAT EVIDENCE POINTS TO THAT
CONCLUSION?
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT IT
WOULD BE AN INADVERTENT LEAK.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN PASSED TO
MAKE IT MORE INFECTIOUS OR
DIRECT GENETIC MANIPULATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HONING IN ON
NOW.
EVERYONE BELIEVING IT WAS AN
ACCIDENT.
ACCIDENTAL LEAKS DO OCCUR.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A PURPOSEFUL
LEAK.
YOU CAN'T DISCOUNT ANYTHING.
>> Martha: THAT IS IMPORTANT.
WHAT ABOUT THE NEWS IN THE
FINANCIAL TIMES TODAY THAT THERE
ARE AT LEAST 59 MAXIMUM BIO
SAFETY LEVEL 4, THE NAME OF
THESE SORTS OF LABS, THAT ARE
PLANNED AROUND THE WORLD SEVERAL
OF THEM ARE IN CHINA.
WHY ARE WE SEEING AN EXPANSION
OF THE LABS THAT DO THIS WORK
AND DOES THAT CONCERN YOU?
>> IT DOES REALLY CONCERN ME.
WE ALL WANT MORE RESEARCH TO BE
DONE IN A DEFENSIVE WAY.
IT CONCERNS ME FOR TWO REASONS.
NUMBER 1, LAB ACCIDENTS DO
OCCUR.
EVEN THESE LABS OPERATE AT MUCH
LOWER SAFETY LEVELS LIKE WE SAW
IN WUHAN.
SECONDLY, THERE'S A LOT OF DUEL
FUNCTION RESEARCH.
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT,
WHETHER WE WOULD LIKE TO ADMIT
IT, THERE ARE OFFENSIVE
BIOLOGICAL PROGRAMS AROUND THE
WORLD.
YOU KNOW THE ACTORS THAT DO
THAT.
THIS COULD BE USED FOR THOSE
NEFARIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE
NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL AND
WATCHFUL.
>> Martha: ARE YOU NOW SURPRISED
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK THAT THERE
WERE ANY U.S. DOLLARS GOING TO
THE WUHAN LAB TO DO ANY KIND OF
COLLABORATIVE RESEARCH?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
THE NIH FUNDS SO MANY THINGS.
I WAS SURPRISED THERE WEREN'T
MORE CONTROLS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
THAT DIDN'T EXIST.
WE NEED A REBOOT OF OUR RESEARCH
PROCESS FOR FOREIGN INVESTMENTS.
>> AND WE KNOW THIS WOMAN CALLED
THE BAT LADY.
SHE WEARS THIS COMPLETE BIO
HAZMAT SUIT.
SHE'S ON THE LIS